cares of guys my name is jenna and i am
back from my holiday in germany so over
the past month you probably would have
seen it there would have been no videos
but i'm back now so the videos are going
to continue and i'm here to talk a bit a
bit about where this kind of like a
monthly channel update video again huh
where i'm going to talk about where this
is going to go and what not and what my
plans are so i actually asked you guys
what you want me to do because i
currently have I think well I really
have only got 2 Series active right now
game programming and Sparky okay both
those series are like what i like to
call active which means that i'm
actively kind of doing videos on them
but unfortunately because of time
constraints and whatnot it's kind of
hard for me to focus on a particular
thing right well I'm sorry what a man is
it's kind of hard for me to focus on too
many things right I can't make I can't
basically have two different series and
devote an equal amount of attention to
both them because as you can imagine as
you as you probably would have seen over
the past six months or so I've kind of
been working on game programming a bit
and like putting out like let's say five
videos and then I'll switch to Sparky
and put out five videos so the point is
like it's kind of it's not really
balanced and it's not like I'm putting
out you know two videos a week and
they're both from different series I
like to kind of focus on a project work
on it a bit and then let it rest for
like a month or so while I work on
something else and that's kind of how
this channel been going but I don't
really want to do that and now that I've
got even less time it's really not
really option anymore so what I've done
is because I don't know what you guys
want and this channel is pretty much all
about you guys and making the content
that you want to see I i made a straw
poll and I I tweeted it so these are the
results on the screen right now um I
only really gave you guys two choices
and then there was like a general other
third choice and you can see that the
overwhelming majority want game
programming okay well not the
overwhelming majority but 58 Sam won't
game programming which is you know
that's a lot of people so that seems to
be where this is going
so I'm going to continue making game
programming a bit more than Sparky now
I've kind of stopped working on Sparky
too much in like whilst live streaming
you probably would have noticed while I
was away if you were following the
github repository that I did commit
quite a few things and I started I think
all i started work on 3d for Sparky but
I don't think I've committed any code
for summary well I haven't really got
anything to show you um but obviously
that's a very complex process of kind of
started doing that and I also want to
start making tools for Sparky as well
and what I mean by that is like a level
editor because you need you obviously
need to have tools with the game edge
and otherwise writing code is going to
be not very efficient at all so that's
kind of the idea so there's a lot of
work on Sparky and a lot of it a lot of
it is stuff that isn't necessarily too
difficult because you know laying down a
basic game engine is quite easy it's
just very time consuming because a lot
of people for some reason underestimate
the amount of work that actually goes
into a game mentioned there is a lot
that you you could spend years making
just a 2d engine easily ok it there's
just a lot of stuff that goes into a
game mention so because of that I think
that it's the the sea reason isn't
appealing to you guys as much because
it's not really about making games it's
about making the underlying technology
and I mean my channels always been about
making games and of course if I start
making videos about how to make games
that's going to interest much more
people than how to make engines so I
know that a lot of you are really really
really interested in engines and
unfortunately there aren't too many like
apart from just downloading already made
source code for a engine such as unreal
for example excuse me or anything
awesome or so many similar to that you
there really isn't like a step-by-step
kind of tutorial on how to make your own
game engine so I think that's kind of
unique the fact that I'm doing that but
on the other hand it also means that I'm
smaller audience and that's kind of bad
because I wanted channel to grow
obviously and and I generally like it
when more people watch my video so I can
kind of see the relation between these
and because of that over the next year
or so this is almost like me holding a
board meeting and honestly like the way
that I like treating this channel though
like it's almost like me just holding a
board meeting with all my investors and
laying out the plan for the next
financial year because that seems to be
exactly what's going on here but the
idea is that um because I'm kind of
making this content for you it's kind of
important for me to go through all this
and then hear your feedback so what's
going to happen over the next year or so
as I said is I'm going to kind of move
the direction back to games so Sparky is
still going to be a thing ok I will
probably work a lot on Sparky outside of
of like YouTube and twitch I'll still
try and stream once a week or so but i'm
going to move a bit away from that and
i'm going to i enjoy working on Sparky
more than on games so i'll probably
continue doing that in my own time and
obviously people following the github
repository will be able to see changes
whenever I put in something exciting
i'll make a video about it and
eventually I might start doing specific
in-depth videos on particular on
particular features or techniques or
anything that i had to sparky really so
that i can be like oh here's how i did
this you know here's how i added um I
don't know masking or something yes
here's how I added like I shared a
compiler or something even difficult
like something really complex probably
like that here's how i added deferred
rendering or something like that right
so it'll be difficult as in it'll be
like they'll be they'll be large feature
yet like they'll be um a lot kind of
significant features and then talk about
them in dedicated videos but other than
that is just going to be live stream or
offline and that's kind of developing as
blocky because I do want to gross
barking to being a game engine that can
be used to make games in kind of the
same way that unity is used so it should
have its own scripting language it
should have its own editor it should be
like the workflow should be easy and
that is going to take a lot of time
but you know it's kind of like my
project so that's kind of what I'm
working on but yeah so don't worry
Sparky is still going to continue I'm
not counseling that series or anything
game program is going to kind of kind of
take precedence I guess over Sparky and
going to be my priority as far as
YouTube goes so I'm going to bring that
back and hopefully we'll be able to do
things now because that series is almost
three years old it will be three years
old in October there are there's a lot
of online code that that sucks because
I've obviously matured as a programmer
and as a game developer and I know that
a lot of things that I wrote there are
not very good i think that is written in
Java which is also unfortunate kind of
because it means that it means that it's
not as good as it could be but that's
okay i'm not going to do something
drastic like changed language or
something because i like the fact that
java is quite a simple language and it's
quite easy to write code it doesn't
require it doesn't require you to be a
really good programmer if that makes
sense it's almost like a scripting
language is kind of like c sharp right c
sharp has some very advanced features
which is nice but Java really doesn't
have those I mean it's it does now like
they're adding some more advanced things
like lambdas and whatnot but it it you
know it's kind of simple which is why I
do like it this also brings back 3d
amber going now 3d game programming is
also what i feel it's almost in the same
boat as Sparky okay i mentioned i think
i've mentioned this earlier that excuse
me I think I mentioned this earlier but
I was going to originally bring back 3d
game programming as like a refresh so I
would basically do it from the start and
called the old series legacy so they're
bit legacy 3d game programming series so
I dad like a legacy in square brackets
in front of like every video and then I
started again except I'd do it you know
properly because back then I had like I
want to say less than six months of
experience I've ever met in like
programming basically so I'm I did
obviously a lot of the code is just
horrific but that being said I don't
know if it belongs with this new kind of
all that I've set up for this channel
well we're kind of making games because
that series is almost more about making
a ray casting engine which is cool and
very informative and really really good
right it's it's it's a really nice topic
and it's something that is quite
difficult to do but that is more of an
engine than a game so I don't know what
her lies with you guys the problem is if
I start making videos about games it's
almost like this channel is going to
turn into like a unity tutorial Channel
and I don't want to do that because
there are plenty of those and you know
something that i dislike unity or
anything it's it's quite nice but it's
just I feel like I feel like I'm above
that if that makes sense I feel like I
feel like if I use unity I'm not really
using my abilities because it's so easy
if that makes sense right because if I'm
just using unity then you know I've got
all this other knowledge about this low
level stuff that is basically I can't
apply anymore and thus I can't make
videos about so that's also a problem
and I have to think about that as well
but anyway this has been more of like an
open discussion with you guys I'm really
interested in what you have to say about
my thoughts and whatnot about this
channel and where I should go from here
but expect more kind of interaction with
you I'm going to if you leave comments
on this video I'm going to spend when
it's been quite a bit of time flying to
almost everyone who comments here if
they have something to say other than
looking forward to it or something but
that's kind of the idea right now um
that's where my that that's my kind of
feeling of where I think this should go
and if you disagree or agree we have
other thoughts are there are specific
videos that you want to see one other
thing I was going to do is maybe make
some actual tutorial series so not like
hey watch me make a game and I'll
explain stuff but more like this is how
you this is this is how this is you know
let's learn java let's learn C++ let's
learn OpenGL that kind of stuff like
actually learning the technologies
rather than using it to make a game so
we might do something
like that as well that was what I kind
of meant by other by the way but we'll
see how this goes so thank you for
watching and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye